open the curtain Johnny
[Applause]
whoa welcome welcome to welcome to a
delightful fireside chat with the Doug
Stanhope podcast thank you all for
coming
this is going to be weird we try to
figure out how this works we don't know
we haven't done it it's a brand new art
form for us live podcasting so it's
going to get [ __ ] up and weird so make
yourselves at home
take care your waitstaff and they will
over pour you don't drive I get a lot of
notes everyone's [ __ ] wrecked it's
usually me you had try not to heckle too
much don't answer rhetorical questions
because we do have to put this out so
are you ready for the cash let's bring
everyone out first right here I believe
is my co-host mr. Chad shank
I'm
our producer and that's his only job mr.
Gregg chaley that fifth chair over there
we're going to have people coming in and
out of that but our special guests that
came all the way back to Bisbee because
you sold him the first time
Burt the crusher Kreischer see while we
were getting drunk Burt what happened
was I on the top of my list of notes get
Birds credits because I wanted to bring
you out with all your credits what's the
name of the Netflix special I don't have
one what no I show talk show time oh
they still have that they still have
cable hey Patrice O'Neal did a Showtime
special a long time ago by like 13 years
ago and I said I went to the filming and
I brought some friends and I and he got
done and we were in his green room and I
said hey man congratulations and he
looked at me goes it's show time
all right [ __ ] you're special because
I'm not done bringing most reported
people out is there a bar staff Tracy
and bingo
I just figured this out we're recreating
the [ __ ] fun hell yeah I think we're
to God when we got on stage I go what
the [ __ ] up with the tiki bar oh [ __ ]
they're coming so long Eddie's bars
Chios Eddie's we'll explain it later
let's look at this beforehand
I just saw the backdrop are you [ __ ]
[ __ ] me
it says the funhouse and I didn't
realize it was dark
hang on I first find out in light I got
to get to the last I got to get the last
introduction first person because he's
the drunkest sitting in you might know
mr. Brian Hennigan the filthy untouched
[Music]
[Applause]
all right sorry I said no too many
[ __ ] faces so I'll try to look this
way [ __ ] sure just came out of a
serious bender he has not slept and he's
refusing any offers of uppers because
he's heard the bad Yelp reviews about
Bisby hello he he greedily they move and
fold your clothes for an hour he just
came out of the what's he called the
Vegas carpet out in Roseville as some
shitty festival in Vegas where he hasn't
slept since Vegas and we've been we've
been going since I've been going pretty
hard in the pain yeah that's all I can
say I've been partying pretty hard I was
partying yesterday I got the IV I got
the b12 shot and then I was started
drinking at 6:00 in the morning to do
press and I drank all day did he show
two shows last night drank all night
slept two hours came in here drank all
on the time of the plane if my liver
makes it I'll be shot that's what I say
every time I go to the funhouse I said
to my doctor the last time I went to
physical I said this is the last time
I'm gonna come in here and go am i dying
like I said next time I come here I'm
gonna look healthy and she was like
[Music]
blabs lost a shitload of weight let me I
got to get a read on the audience so I
can see my Bisbee people up there
out-of-towners
I go out a play D is separately separate
but equal hey I can't big enough here
when you face everybody equal I think
about when they did equality in America
so going on Oh
back in the sixties in the state not
transgenders of black and white old
school equality you know who must've
buggin been irate is the dude who made
water fountains cuz he was seldom two at
a time and may cut his business in half
can I get a double Tito's and soda
please I got far we got it lined you
have our own sauce the [ __ ] up it's the
funhouse Bert yeah I can't believe I
really can't believe I did not recognize
that's what we're doing
you're not really an observational comic
okay
is that in your act observational ISM no
that's not that fit that's not a girl
urge little bit no no we just burned it
you just wasted a bit on a podcast I
said I said oh thank you so much uh I
said [ __ ] strong [ __ ] I wish yeah
but I don't do jokes like that ends up
worse than one of the lowlights of my
weekend was a Telugu I don't really like
storyteller comics and I was like like
that's my whole gig I wish I have more
bits like that well yeah that's what
Netflix said
[Applause]
Hennigan has been murdering it since I
saw him this morning I've been drinking
since you saw him this morning every dog
has his day they flew out from Los
Angeles together yes no I check on we're
going hard as [ __ ] on Monday that's
right oh you know I ever taking edge of
the streets taking it to the street yeah
but but we're keeping it real sounds
better on a black person perfect we're
taking it to this tree is oh I'm really
[ __ ] up yeah oh that's amazing
come on Vegas was pretty cool it was
really fun no it was a piece of [ __ ] and
everyone knows it in the comedy
community and they'll be listening to
this podcast John yeah it was good money
how many shows oh good funny how many
shows did they canceled they canceled a
lot but not mine yeah some for the
audience we have to address the fact
that people are here live they tried to
sum up start a comedy festival in Vegas
where's some douchebag that didn't know
how to run a festival but knew how to
write a check got a lot of really good
comedians there but no audience showed
up okay I can't be a part of this
because I like the guy I haven't got
your check yet no I got my check did you
yeah that's a Marshalls are sold out
yeah yeah but you haven't gotten paid
well it's called Judy Brown and see
what's over whoa if I don't get paid
I'll be [ __ ] I'll be I'll be happy
I could walk away from that happy did
you yeah yeah yeah it was a big ego
boost its comedy festivals comedy
vegetables are [ __ ] insane because
it's it is sometimes it's the best
comics like like when we did the end of
the world podcast someone said to me you
know this you know this show it was it
for those who don't know is me Stanhope
bill burr and Joe Rogan and I think
basically that I was there to catch
anchor yeah by the way by the way the
people on that like Marilyn Manson was
there it was a [ __ ] insane lineup
someone was like you realized this would
be like a 300 ollar comedy ticket and
that's the cool thing about festivals
like last night I was laughing my dick
off with the funniest comics in the
world
it's just howling laughing we pull up
they told us out of a private jet this
is where I knew they were lost money
closed up the private jet immediate I
was like man can to check quick if it
man it was R it was really fun they're a
lot of really talented comedy the comedy
community is the size of Bisbee just
comedians yeah so imagine if like all of
Bisbee you all lived everywhere else but
came here once a year for a festival
like [ __ ] I proposed me kiddo [ __ ] be
pissed because that's what festivals are
like where you're meeting up with all
hey I see Burt maybe once a year
Hennigan too often but my comics
comedian friends you see him only when
you happen across ads on the road so
when you're all in one place and you
outnumber the suits and the Booker's
even the audience
[ __ ] the audience yeah we're party it's
it's worth it even if your check bounces
yeah
now I'm concerned about that there's no
way they made out hi guys yeah you
should be maybe half of Alabama yeah oh
yeah so yeah you're 56 Crips I'm sure
you'll get paid up and it tastes taking
the tyro and Eva tell Bert Bert has a
Bert was only in Bisbee once before yeah
last year and it was overnight you got
in it like 5 o'clock
we got shit-faced and bingo had to drive
you to the airport
let's not get off on how that story went
that was the start of the desperate
measures to her yeah an Amber Alert and
a mental institution later here you are
oh that you have no idea there's there's
so many secrets about that drive that I
wanted to share uh yeah we won't get
about it don't happen
don't tell us st. David is boring it was
uh it was really [ __ ] it was like
getting it to get a secret bingo is like
I'm running away and I was like what the
[ __ ] do I do with this knowledge called
I don't know like Doug called me and
he's like he's like uh are you a bingo
Oh like I am I got a secret I don't want
to tell you yet I swear to god there's
so many things I wanted to leave I was
gonna have washed up Willy all those you
said I wasn't wrong but he's out of town
he's got the town well he don't isn't he
always our two identities is that he
doesn't have a town I thought that was
his gig yeah that was a fun
I was really fun what tomorrow he says
he has a lot of plans oh I got big blue
your plans oh my gosh yeah I have a
lunch planned a lunch yeah I want to do
like a big lunch where we all go out I
so badly want to get dressed in suits
and play tennis like this oh we can do
that will you still have the rackets we
haven't used for 10 years I think I
might just take a xanax
though that's what I assumed when you
were saying that after telling me you
have not slept since Vegas yeah you have
a lot of plans for lunch and shopping in
stuff oh I just want to experience at
all that's the problem me I have a hard
time saying no you could do that tonight
yeah this is pretty much it but the
women in Bisbee we all agree are the
hottest women of the world I've seen so
many cosmetics who's been drinking from
fudging drunk those three sisters you
were talking to you know the three
sisters Hannigan's their names are the
shenanigans
then their three sisters yes I wanna go
ballistic manager talked about a
threesome I had a threesome with the
shenanigans sounds like you had a
threesome and got the shenanigans oh I
could start a new family I see it this
is where I want to tell the Lin chakra
story that just happened oh yeah oh but
Lin should I not tell that story right
now no you should definitely tell it oh
hey I'm waiting for Linda to say no she
too busy talking is she not
if you're not [ __ ] listening then
[ __ ] you yeah yes god damn airplane no
show yes you so can I tell this story or
not yes or no the one that just happened
in front of the house across from the
shenanigans all right all right I knew
we should have Mike backstage my god let
me set the scene so we pull off innocent
well bring you out later cuz you're
gonna come up yeah back to this limbs a
bit Daffy okay
uh Lynn and she's she's a wreck I'm
trying to find a local reference but
you're not local mostly so go ahead set
the scene so we're in a surprisingly
expensive suburban what for bhisma you
mean I have to picking any dolls in the
back the suburban cost more than Jay
Lee's house and we're heading for
Mexican border yeah mium Thank You Liam
right Eric centre and the way back Doug
realizes he recognizes this is an hour
ago
girl playing the ukulele in the street
and he says hi towards his shenanigans
it's her two sisters comes out and we're
waiting for Lynne the whole time
Waveland
what's that movie with George Clooney
with the big teeth Ocean's eleven no the
site silenced
Ocean's Twelve hello old brother where
are their three sisters my god it's all
my [ __ ] The Iliad and the Odyssey
three sisters come out once more ukulele
- were kind of hot hang around God I did
not I did not make this connection
earlier about incredibly drawn to leave
the suburban I was wait you're not
setting the scene this scene is we have
to be here at seven o'clock sharp
Lynne shocked Rob says don't leave me
behind
I'm going to have my phone on we're at
the air B&B over beside behind the house
and I call her doesn't answer then I
call her then I go straight to voicemail
then I call her then you get that
Mexican thing where you're like do do do
whatever she's like you got the wrong
signal because you're too close to the
border so we're all in the suburban hold
on but dog is talking to three sisters I
know I don't we're not there your hair
color t-bird when we have to go bang on
her feet oh yeah
yeah but hang on sarang's door at the
air B&B i go in saying hey we're leaving
everyone's waiting up front now it's
after 7:00 and I walk in and she's naked
from the top up and she's got partials
like a lot of us we're missing a lot of
teeth it's been a long road
fortunately mine are all in the back
first so we got [ __ ] spatial [ __ ]
missing teeth naked and I thought she
got out of the shower but the Airbnb has
no air conditioning so it's just sweat
like I'll go what yeah go straight my
phone was charging and but does
statement sauce is surprisingly nice
breast
oh I always had an ID right surprised
when I press but then dog separates talk
to the three sisters and we rocketed up
waiting waited she shocked Rob says give
me 90 seconds I'll be right down I go
we'll just come like you are and then
she mocked and chakras might have done
it
come here just sweating topless and
toothless just she's that cool but I go
no no no no like there are no teeth no
there she's got so she's you know that
she came here with no teeth like I'm
just gonna do this what all right now we
get to where I'm gonna have to wait
the fortunately I had a road cocktail
and that's when the other eight of you
fat bastard's are stuck in the eighth
row of the suburban we're waiting for
Lin and then but the line is perfect on
the way it was delivered so Doug is
taking on bill the street talking these
three sisters Lin comes out no shoes
toothbrush in her mouth brushing her
teeth
gets in the car and someone says hey I
think you forgot your teeth no no no dad
it was Doug who [ __ ] Jess she went
out she gave us her Perret and a
toothbrush and some others like she
spilled her purse in the road as she's
jumping in
all of our [ __ ] goes everywhere and I
said I assume you have your teeth on you
wait oh I got a run back up the way boy
wait the line is dug goes back to Tyler
sister I had to bound up his stuff and
turns around and gets it sticks his head
of the suburban it goes
she brought her toothbrush one on her
teeth I'm picking up Oliver [ __ ] had
spilled on the seat here Saturday in
what Institute out loud himself but to
us we went every we watching Oleg
scribbles the [ __ ] all of us all of us
that bastard stuck in the suburban we're
laughing her ass off oh that's why I
knew these are completely pointless like
we're trying to hey how do we do a live
podcast make it educate that we yeah we
got some stories there if we need them
but yeah just getting here how did you
take your teeth out I can't see that's
because they're looking away nerd for
the listener of the podcast
shock Rob just stuck her head out the
window laughing style missing teeth
saying I lose him a lot but people just
can't tell words the joke - [ __ ] the
listeners but you said laughing style I
think you lost everybody laughing stud
that's I see I told you Shaunie
dude listen Oh hold on Lin Lin I'm gonna
walk without women die save it for later
we're going to bring you out last we
tried to listen to Bert's phenomenal
stories on the drive from Tucson today
and Burt would say oh yeah one time I
killed a guy with a uh an ice pick and
she goes
you know what I like is uh I see so you
went over Italian ice ice and good he's
got great stories in one word sends her
straight into boring yeah I was very
glad you were gripping the wheel of that
point because you're so visibly angry
and the booth shakes yeah I gotta drive
and listen at the same time there's a
part of my brain that was like I can't
believe I'm laying Stanhope drive me
three hours somewhere like party goes
like [ __ ] this is white-knuckle in it no
I like her Michael been sober for three
hours in 20 years
it was you when I sleep I assume uh we
we stayed overnight and uh anyway we
pick up bird at the airport and I had
one beer waiting for him but he shows up
needing a drink really bad and so we go
back to the hotel we stayed at where my
beer is waiting for me and I chug my
beer da yeah I need a drink but I think
you thought that I'd been drinking the
whole time I definitely did but he
definitely did well it's a safe
assumption because I would never drive
drunk I don't have you have to Lynn was
lit no she had one drink in the
reservoirs here she was she was lit
Beetlejuice Beetlejuice typing thank you
so much
point being I told Burt we got to
suburban yeah you can drink on the drive
let's not sit here any longer at this
bar just drink is we're going to be late
anyway getting back drink and then when
we stopped at the pilot for mixers cuz I
was it has who's in the car not for me
but for guests I'm a host we got booze
in the car just drink in the back of the
suburban we stop for mixtures and it you
looked at me and you said what do you
got iced tea yeah I thought you were
drinking that's I didn't put it together
to later oh I was like just what doing
what mixture I'm having when I'm driving
two hours yeah no I'm not drinking who
cuts vodka with iced tea I swear to god
I was like I was like August has money
to drink iced tea and vodka it's not
that I've done that Burt Burt had no
expectation that you would be sober
driving him from home from to start hey
why chuckling you know when Jay Lee is
not here I'm a very good mirror of
chilly III take care of my [ __ ]
but if you're here oh no I'm sober [ __ ]
it's your job now the Sharks breakfast
uh you're Mike that's the Bisbee jury
right there that's all of our Frances oh
is that Margo is here Oh Margo is here
well that's a good thing you are coming
nurse Betty is here neighbor Dave is
here Lucy say John from redbone if you
want to buy a bucking Doug Stanhope for
bingo outfit nurse Betty's back there
Gabe Oh Gabe you came anyway you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
okay I got you Jeff don't worry I'm
going I can't do everyone hang on
everything been mentioned on the podcast
nobody knows who you are I'm talking to
the people we love you Gabe right before
the show tonight
text me um there's some confusion is
this a comedy show tonight or a podcast
not that your podcasts aren't funny with
all sarcastic eye grows a dagger of
doubt into your heart clearly on brown
paper tickets it says this will not be a
comedy show actually on the I know but
perceptive --'tis note Gabe's strong
point that's true
google that word Gabe and come back to
us when you see understood strong point
Burt your tomorrow should you make it
through what what are your plans we you
want to have lunch somewhere where do
you want to have lunch you want to go to
Mexico I'm not oh yeah yeah yeah I was
thinking of like a cool place that has a
lot of like earthy tones poco and I
wanted to like I wanted a big table hope
you'll be showing up I want people to
say stuff like Oh last night was [ __ ]
crazy right yeah big table I say I think
vocals only played love it by the way
when do you say tomorrow is going to be
[ __ ] up you sent me the note but just
tell people there is an after party
after this great new jungle the green
wristband you got them green repent all
right yeah it's down the street and then
you take a left walk it's just ask
someone where are Elmo's and then go
across the street to where the crowd of
people you were sitting next to are no
not giving specific directions is how we
weed people out yeah if you can't figure
it out it's not that big of town they're
going to be at Elmo's what does this get
me I have a green wristband elmo's is
like the busy loon Phung what was that
and I would put you on first we can
whatever help me get it anybody who's on
first
Hennigan so yeah there's an after party
there once we're done and we were
selling merch others are hanging out
that will be over there go find Hertz
you get a book merch wait you guys said
there was gonna be an open mic at the
after party what we said a lot of things
was I was just question to miss I don't
know that's is there a mic well that
seemed like the most interesting part of
the whole evening and we we reciting
contracts and then immediately disowned
them so war it's like the after part is
the sting with breakfast who's staying
the weekend all right breakfast
morning's cafe in the Waring district
that's why I call tomorrow
whoa someone will direct you to the
Bisbee breakfast club or whatever boo I
don't know they I light a food they have
great food it's too far but for us where
we live in the Warren District keep
Warren boring they have morning's cafe
where I go because it's stumbling
distance from my house but I still drive
everyone knows my name with is Z I just
I wanted to do this just for Bisbee this
big breakfast club has a t-shirts that
say I couldn't wait I saved this for
this podcast they have their slogan is
Bisbee Breakfast Club often copied never
duplicated where you have any kind of
marketing sense first of all you're
stealing a hackneyed cliched catchphrase
wrong
[Laughter]
often imitated never duplicated so you
have often copied never duplicated which
means the same thing so they wear these
t-shirts with pride and safe serve the
tourists and uh I ate there once because
it was a Thursday and I know that
because that's the only day that
mornings is closed so I went there for
breakfast and I loved it :
that um I brought up the t-shirt thing
and they said well copied and duplicated
and they stuttered this they never
thought of it I'm just checking here's
the thing you know how I am on stage you
can't be a dick in a small town like
that so I'm trying to
passive-aggressively be a [ __ ]
where I'm like your [ __ ] t-shirt
there's no sense how did I have to do it
like shuffle and jive you know how we
get along we all get along here and then
once they got through there bad
explanation I said haven't you opened
another location and they go no two and
a third and the worst
[Laughter]
so they're worse than you because if you
try to copy but it can't duplicate those
other locations
I could stay away I left it at that
check please okay please when we were in
high school our coach made us t-shirts
for our baseball team that said 10%
talent a hundred percent our work didn't
say we stuck on the back
Oh buddy yeah you guys how about 1%
[ __ ] we just thought that I didn't
understand anything you said it now
absolutely oh I like that fan are we
going to talk about busy stuff nine
well yeah we're done with Bisby stuff
already I've heard a number the Copper
Queen what the Copper Queen yeah what
you said you wanted to uncle got done
there Oh what was old please I wanted to
talk to Burt he's our guest
oh yeah yeah [ __ ] star yeah Burt the
conjurer's that
the machine nope let me sleep let me
drop some credits for the locals is your
Travel Channel show still on burn to
conquer is that still going real fire
it's on sometimes I hear did they
replace you with another Bert uh no how
about triplet burn come on abhi is yes
can I googled it that is I got Bert
Kreischer as a guest I go is convey
available canto you said Mirko
wongburger camford is the number one
bird Wow
yeah like when I go to German a lot
[ __ ] Germans know they uh yeah yeah
I'm not working for travel till anymore
so well you had to [ __ ] those credits
yeah [ __ ] that
alright I don't see Bert anywhere except
on Showtime you guys everyone in Bisbee
steals everything anyway they find it on
YouTube I'll do that where we're talking
about that today without like the only
reason I'm selling any tickets right now
it's cuz a Facebook [ __ ] videos that
went viral on Facebook
what's Facebook holy [ __ ] man you're
right about this town yeah welcome to
club him love the busy they all got
ukuleles but no one's got a computer
three huh
we had a bunch of [ __ ] go viral on
Facebook and it was the best thing are
we were talking about this today I was
like I just want to do a special and put
it on Facebook I know I explained why
you should know do still disagree uh-huh
well well we'll talk about that on the
flight back all right technically all we
have a phone oh I have to go down so
then let me look at my watch because we
will be telling the intermission so you
can smell we got yeah we could like I'll
let you know it's like an old-school
Merkley is like Doctor Zhivago
oh I'll do my material this will do
crowd wrath while we're doing
intermissions and people are smoking so
you feel like you came for a reason and
you're we're acknowledged and I'll go
hey what do you do and then I'll just
that's great and then hey where you from
I I just told myself this would be like
a regular podcast except lots of people
both Arna but
I didn't ever take into the fact this
would be the first podcast where I just
couldn't smoke weed whenever I want
believe me that's what made me think of
intermission I can smoke cigarettes weed
however but I he has a rape story or
will be here the whole time
oh I'm not going anywhere now the hope
is that it's not a race time are we are
you ready I want to want to do that on
after the break or do you want to I want
to get a thousand things that Bert and I
have a couple things you know what oh
[ __ ]
what pit that's a great move my legs
away that's a great piece how about I'll
done let's close on this because it's a
loft I haven't my notes but I would get
sha croft in for this just Road trivia
[ __ ] maybe I shouldn't do this maybe I
should check what are you doing no no I
work this I I know what you're doing
this will take longer than what I'm
thinking right you won't end on that
yeah
oh you definitely going alright get some
more time here shad Schenck you were
raped when you're at all I didn't mean
that
oh this is not how I thought this whole
showing you this the return that I
didn't know they do cities that do
setting heal cities everybody the
perfect Bloody Mary mixture nurse Betty
sells that t/o cities we got we got ours
today at Ace Hardware its industrial
keel City I bought it off your old water
fell on this town after Ace Hardware I
bought a book on pay by a local author
that was fantastic the people's history
of Bisbee but they sold it at the
hardware store it's a [ __ ] great town
why don't you live here Tom Konopka you
should be selling [ __ ] houses instead
of blue apron ear there's a [ __ ]
perfect host alright should we do should
we do it everyone should we do a break
yeah let's have some order pizza
yes I would love a pizza right now all
right take a break
let's we're going to take a small
intermission so let's say seven minutes
looks like how long is a grill play some
music yes Nate the music you can yeah
but of course I want heart crazy on you
I accept that song what I don't know the
[ __ ] internet here I've got I've got
30 days in the hole
can you play hockey player first loud
yes word cloud large cloud above
everyone loves the bird cloud too late
alright and now we're at break don't
worry
right when we had drinks we're at break
you're a break but don't think we're not
recording don't come up and say hey I'm
[ __ ] this problem child while my wife
is in the [ __ ] insane asylum she's
only 15 but she wanted to meet you
because they're taping still we will
record that alright so are we gonna take
a break let's do some yeah you go take a
break no this is a break oh no I'm gonna
play music oh [ __ ] yeah no she's vote in
sorry telly story yeah I don't even know
how this works would happen yeah well we
did tease him with the rape story again
we'll come back so recording yeah at
this point I have to tell the story just
so people down the guy got raped you did
I'm gonna [ __ ] argue with that
alright alright we're done for great
point-counterpoint segment with Chad and
I please hold
I think we're taking a break we'll be
right back we'll play about three or
four songs hey here's a Bert crisis
request bird cloud have a drink have a
smoke we'll be right back
uh table cannot tell us about your
latest victory while we were out of town
of eating an entire meal for two by
yourself let's see
off of the last podcast what was it was
I talked about the Persian cucumber was
the tandoori style chicken and rice that
you had fun with but if we have no idea
what podcast this is coming off oh
that's even better
sometimes we yeah we if we we did over
one thing about Steve Harvey yeah I went
out before the thing that we did after
the thing or who knows the thing anyway
we go out of town a lot because we go on
the road and you sit here and scarf up
all the free blue apron well let me say
yes Ida this week actually this is a
fare somewhere later this week it's
going to be a stir fried wonton noodles
with bok choy and radishes this I do
look forward to because I've only I
think I've done maybe one or two maybe
one stir-fry with blue apron that was
killer and it's back to the farik aqui
para cada Ferry khaki is back it's I
didn't even remember what the hell it
was but I remember the taste it's dried
seaweed and sesame seeds I got savory
seasoning for fish yeah but this is
going to be what I liked I was just
telling Shaylee you get the fresh wonton
noodles and these are fresh anybody it's
ever done any fresh pasta or anything
like that you're not doing eight to nine
minutes all dente with this it's 2 to 4
minutes it is a fast dish it's got the
baby bok choy - yeah let me guess I'm
going to cut through some [ __ ] right
here cut cuz Tom brought this up today
which is exactly what I would do blue
apron sends you all the exact
ingredients you need to make a perfect
meal but if you're a [ __ ] like us you
know it came with pork chops I don't
give a [ __ ] about [ __ ] but I'm just
gonna make the pork chop to a point it
won't poison me I'm going to eat that
and throw the rest of this [ __ ] the
trash either way you get [ __ ] delivered
to your door
yeah it is all good no matter how you
move it around you end up with something
that is really really [ __ ] yeah if
you want to be a smart [ __ ] and try to
impress a woman with a lot of furikake
but if you don't you're just a dude
sitting alone staring at your bloat
belly that's blocking your Netflix binge
is one of them put a piece of meat in my
mouth
whoa we're like a lazy old dog slowly
eating it without even cutting it I just
want to put one whole pork chop in my
face and slowly chew on it like a long
piece of jerky you can do that you don't
have to make all the you know what it
says forty minutes or less for these
meals Oh No if you put a piece of meat
in a microwave oh my god wait a minute
you go I get I got my first three meals
free I'm gonna eat them like jerky and
[ __ ] all the couscous I'd gonna eat meat
so I don't vomit blood after I finish
off this jug of Old Crow exactly so what
else did I where's exactly what else did
you throw away you know I I didn't know
I didn't notice that uh I'm Tom you
you've actually bought bok choy separate
no no absolutely this is actually
company I have no I've done it okay for
vegetables and trying to use my just
lean proteins and vegetables and trying
to cut down on carbs but man I don't you
know invite buying too much card well
you may say I'm elite anybody nobody
knows tom has eaten anything I try to
get put on a little bit of muscle but I
trying to lay it down a little bit and
that's a great thing about no apron is
they there's no waste if you use that
product there's no waste
I hate waste but I'm the only guy that
eats what I eat bingo doesn't eat
anything but weird [ __ ] so if I want
like a Egg McMuffin I have to buy six
[ __ ] English muffins that will go
stale or rotten or moldy before I can
eat more than two yeah hey what was that
thing you like sneak them into Tom and
somehow they end up gone who and then I
make fun of them for not losing weight
no you call me a liar
they did take umbrage to good luck
English muffins
into his [ __ ] region and then no he
goes cinnamon I am trying to stay off
bread I go I I love you English muffins
and you ate him you liar and then the
next day he brought it up okay when we
left the Airbnb you found something that
bingo left in a drawer what was it we
were talking about like bingo eats like
she has odd things but she had lasted
evil or eel with cottage cheese I
believe in the microwave to the point
where it becomes cement and then she
eats it at night like grout yummy twice
I'm [ __ ] for her Katja Jesus Christ
but it works for she's looking right
she's in bed at 3:00 in the morning the
sound she's too lazy to go and put it in
the sink so we're in a [ __ ] air B&B I
Chi puts it in the top drawer of the
dresser and the only reason I found it I
was looking for something that we never
use the dressers it in hotel oh my eye
mask from my [ __ ] chill Asian and I
couldn't find it elation and and then I
open a drawer and there's this happy
bowl of grout pretty good high five I
guess a crowd you know they they rate us
if she were aware of stars that you get
no like yeah bingo you're getting
publicly reviewed on our stand
and we get three stars because of your
grout cement bowl of stink that you have
nothing you know [ __ ] dresser drawers
on the skirts empty cans as you finish a
can of you can club soda and put it back
in the fridge you could put a bowl of
grout on the top of the dresser you are
laying a trap we don't use dressers
we're in hotel so much that when we go
to air baby
we don't use a filter uses a dresser
yeah other than your grandparents when
they're going to be on the cruise ship
for a month yeah hoping they die and
have their ashes cast off the side
anyway speaking of ashes what did you
not burn from blue apron every bit of it
every bit of it worked out great if you
follow the instructions and it is not
that [ __ ] difficult it really is I
was saying it is like cooked by number
it you can read and there's pictures
yeah yes and it's not it's not like a
5x7 recipe card it's a half by eleven
sheet yeah and it's not paper it's it's
a it's like cardstock no yeah I mean we
keep talking about this wallet but one
time we have to get bingo to do blue
apron because I'll shoot honestly we'll
take a frozen pizza and put it in the
microwave for two minutes till it's just
wet still cold and wet and thawed eat
barely thawed
so I want yeah I wouldn't find out what
we want to do a bingo presents blue
apron dud that would be good
the beauty is is like Tom you get you
get the the full meat you get whatever
you want on there you can choose
whatever you want we can do vegetarian
we can we can restrict if they you don't
want to do pork you don't want to do
shellfish or something like that you
could you can oh yeah they're totally
customizable and you're back on you're
getting it weekly now again right yeah
because I because while we were on tour
I got out and I forgot to tell you
so are we we were a few scholarship
I found where we were stocked so you can
go week to week if you're going to be
gone or you want to take a break for a
while you can do that as well so the way
for though it was a fury that busted
your balls behind your back don't worry
I only stylin tell the truth on the
podcast good someone but actually
probably everyone bingo
where you give up quickly you give you
know what you should do for uh for
exercise like Tom you better [ __ ]
lose a few pounds before you give
someone exercises buddy yeah you do have
good posture though it was Kayleigh
it was Kayleigh that did a why am i
doing this little listening audience
it's good right I think you should are
having porn stars oh I can't see you but
Tom Konopka where you have the perfect
posture with the giant [ __ ] gut you
walk like this yeah straight back you
have a face fine right it it's where I
can spined us this right up see the core
is there I was gonna tell her go into
the crawl base today to try to find some
pictures for the book and I saw his
weights out there and I was gonna go see
if I could lift those and I went I have
no interest in lifting these but I know
I don't know what go again no I'm
enjoying the [ __ ] out of the pay as
always a blue apron has been a sponsor
since we started getting sponsors
recently they every month we really
appreciate them you get first three
meals for free just go to blue apron
comm slash Stanhope that's blue apron
comm slash Stanhope and get those first
three meals for free and please do that
get them if you [ __ ] hate them tweet
that you hated them they want to know no
one had want to know
nobody has oh I just said once you would
you get on there in my accountant said
hey send this to a friend I send it to
brereton we were talking about it on the
tour and he goes does this be great I
don't try it I'll send you the link you
get the first three free
when he comes out here on the next
weekend we'll find out how it's going
all right sounds like a winner do it
blue apron calm /span hope blue apron is
a better way to cook especially if
you're a hobo down in tin town cooking
beans and weenies over a open fire
especially in Bisbee where it's fire
season all right everyone
a loud loud fake laughter and applause
for all those smoking people so they
think they're missing something one two
[ __ ] smoker oh man oh [ __ ] and that
was an Afghanistan air stewardess Burt
what yeah oh yeah yeah yeah she's remind
to get a thin so you know we know where
we're going next but doc mark is here
where's doc mark you saved bingos life
dr. mark dr. mark and hello Robin blue
oh hey I was supposed to trade you up
from [ __ ] Erickson I'd forget that
part do it live beat it get Erickson in
here I reason Eric should take
Hannigan's place bred Eric should we
also have Christina being here sharp
rocks got away god damn it we uh we got
a we had a bank robbery here ProFlowers
I just wanted to drop ProFlowers into
this because ProFlowers is a sponsor and
we're not the kind of people that send
flowers we don't have those kind of
relationships where that's necessary so
when there was a bank robbery in the
warren district of Bisbee even yeah we
sent uh flowers to the gals that work
there and yeah and I said the note was
up put your hands up in the air and
party like you just don't care
so yeah even my audience can appreciate
the use of ProFlowers so so far so far
our our commercials have been about pre
sending a spray of flowers to your own
funeral and now a bank robbery which I
think they do more boxes to tick on
what's the occasion I used to try to
write a greeting cards like abortions or
duis and I thought that would be a funny
thing to sell after shows so many ideas
out there hey can I get another thank
you the best bar in the world is where
you don't have to finish your drink
order oh the last time I was with you
guys I got so [ __ ] up that was there
that happened I sold that I shouldn't
say this [ __ ] nevermind
I saw videotape on periscope of us
making out against your will which is a
good segue into the next rape chunk oh
yeah uh you're not supposed to run
towards me when I scream rape there's a
microphone she's a real hero so last
time you got [ __ ] up sorry no no no it
was one of the favorite nights of my
entire life
it really was and if you watch it online
I swear to god it doesn't let down is
that the time I was shooting a vlog and
I shot it and I edited it and it is the
first time I've heard Nathaniel
Radcliffe Ratliffe sob out of it get me
a drink
wait hold on hold on hold on hold on
I'll play it and I swear to god it'll
sell it is the if I woke up so I wake up
at like [ __ ] 6:00 in the morning uh
where did you sleep even I slept in one
of the little house unless the laws um
it's playing right now Stanhope
[Music]
[Applause]
okay okay
here turn it down turn it down I'll stop
it uh stop it stop it away from you -
listen oh this is our whole [ __ ]
podcast oh yeah yeah yeah yeah take a
break here are you ready ready ready
this is me this is 6:00 in the morning
bingos about to run away [ __ ] so
happy I came out here good everyone
just watch the YouTube video yeah I kept
saying I kept saying like right now take
out your phone and watch the YouTube the
rest of and that's unless you have
t-mobile then do it some other place on
the roof on the roof for everybody who
has t-mobile I have a Verizon hotspot
available for you today I said to my
wife when I got home I go we don't sing
enough out loud she was like what I go
when I was a dog we were all singing out
loud
it seems like nothing to see with I go
but there were so many modes where we
all just started singing it was so cool
how drunk did you get her before you
proposed it my wife doesn't get drunk
she does what we call unassisted sleeps
where she's goes to bed like a [ __ ]
Mormon just goes goodnight
this is asleep yeah I got7
registered unassisted sleeps is here oh
I can't even fathom on assistance Lee no
[ __ ] [ __ ] I live I lay in bed and my
brain starts losing its [ __ ] mind
goal we should test some booby traps
unassisted sleep for Chad is suicide by
cop that's technically assisted sleep oh
yes yes I guess you did force someone's
hand oh oh you're coming back I saw I
started calling right there and I
thought maybe I'm just saying I thought
maybe a lot of people left that we have
the all these [ __ ] [ __ ] up here
all my friends when we do live podcasts
at the funhouse they just leave things
there before the [ __ ] out of them but oh
we're charging money and you're gonna be
here oh we can't wait to go listen to
your babbles and more alright Chad shank
and uh told me maybe a month ago maybe
two months ago I told you I oh no no is
before this broke his news you like I
heard this [ __ ] on Benson radio that was
two those two years ago like I said it
Wow just as a reference of how [ __ ] up
our time references two years ago I told
you I heard this when you brought it up
again in the recent months where you
sent the emails because you were bait if
you don't know locals maybe know it's
Benson that's a long way for you even
Benson is the nether region between
Bisbee and everyone else in the world
that nobody knows country radio the guy
that owns the station was playing
late-night PSAs about how to hide your
child porn
no this wouldn't not not that it was
wrong but how to hide it my god it was
and they ran oh it's been two years that
they've been running here it was I want
to go on hold
I emailed him two years ago when I heard
it because because I wanted a copy of
this PSA to play on the fathers I wanted
proof
what is proof I asked him at least for a
transcript so I could read the PSA on
the transcript so we can make fun of it
there's been definitely a handful of
porns and I was like oh that's why I
don't take my computer to the Apple bar
quick Sam horn you ever watch tricks and
porn no no don't look at all like a horn
you get a lady that knows it
yeah quick everyone's hot uh I don't
watch the whole thing I'm not a creep
but like you you mean you finish early
what no right when her boobs hit the
dirt that's when I get hot - swear to
God I dare you not to get your dick hard
when you see this at mud you're like a
little abacus fellow in me unassisted
sleep asleep but yeah I never I can't
even watch when I was when I was a my
wife started and I started dating her
best friend was dating this dude and
they were helping him move and he had a
magazine barely legal
which for a guy doesn't register as like
kiddie porn but to a woman goes barely
legal is he into children and I was
helping the move and I went it's not a
big deal no like this year so I was like
oh yeah [ __ ] that guy he's a poor guy
so back to your story so but he brought
this up just a couple months ago I know
it were a joke and he you forward me the
emails that you had sent to him and he
emailed back saying words I'm glad
someone agrees with me or some books I
did I can relay through the emails he's
like this is the left rules this state
they're just [ __ ] people over like I
don't know it might have been the right
I don't know a lot of his children is a
left or right situation we won't have
that close of election I was such a
diplomat when I emailed this guide like
my friend is a public speaker and he
would be interested in your point of
view because I didn't want to be like my
friend is a stand-up comic and he makes
fun of what you're talking about
but you have to understand that the guy
would have had what I could find an
arguable point about the difference
between looking at it versus doing it
and Arizona has like outrageous some
guys doing a hundred years for looking
at pictures of kids naked in sexual
situations but the difference between
you can argue that but the dude was
giving you specific directions on how to
have a secondary hard drive or some [ __ ]
that I don't even understand and this is
where you put your child born the first
time I heard it I could not believe it I
was like this [ __ ] guy's telling you
how to hide child pornography on the
radio he's the owner of the station
doing these as midnight PSA that's
federally regulated there's someone
watching that right right someone is
[ __ ] the fov when it when it hit
national news recently last weekend and
Chad's like we were gonna do that on the
podcast we would have breaking news
Chris [ __ ] it was last signing moment
like a [ __ ] breaking news guys
wait wait wait I want all of us because
we all do reads on a podcast I want to
all us to do our read for hiding your
kiddie porn
ladies and gentlemen back to Taylor
Swift in a moment but right now I want
to talk to you do you think about
[ __ ] Taylor Swift when he didn't want
to be so mean
guys good how old is Selena Gomez have
you been sitting there googling myself
well it's okay to jack off to her now
that I've got a second hard drive for my
computer Selena Gomez this [ __ ] that is
almost verbatim the commercial there's a
siren
Eric's tonight you're looking at me I
realized I didn't even introduce Brent
Erickson yes I just I still hang out
how about this do you watch Law & Order
SVU and cheer for the bad guys are you
like me are you Catholic
[Laughter]
do you like the $0.06
don't even get that what it's funny oh I
can't believe he's doing read please
keep going
yeah well this uh after Chad was his
breaking news moment was stolen by our
lethargy and getting around to doing
another podcast you had the [ __ ]
evidence you emailed it to me and this
but we just never get around a loser oh
and then it shows up okay okay I'm gonna
interject there's uh sometimes what what
I'm witnessing right now is a moment
where you see something that's so
brilliant and no one realizes how
brilliant it is there's a band called
LFO you know who that is
okay the lead singer has passed away
here leukemia he died but he yes boiler
I did my way did anybody get points in
daesil he was on Howard Stern used to
date jennifer Love Hewitt I know
everything about this [ __ ]
because of Google so his name was rich
he had a lyric in one of his songs that
I caught the same way
Chad caught that advertisement I was
laying in bed do you know what lyric I'm
talking about no oh [ __ ]
you don't need neither do I do yeah I do
yeah yeah he said remember that time in
high school when we broke up before the
prom and you told everyone that I was
gay and I went that is the truest lyric
that's ever been written in music ever
cuz he you know he that he's had with
this girl and he was like I want to be
in a boy band she was like I think he
might be gay
he's like no no no not and he was like
showing videos in sake look at them
don't have anything our look how
beautiful they are and she told everyone
who's gay it's my favorite there have
ever heard and it's just like that when
you heard it I know you set this up but
this was a boy band yeah yeah yeah I
maybe I did something wrong okay one
more one more
yeah do you know the name of song uh
we're not playing at the auto whistle
this guy was a rape victim that's why
Chad uh how long he was you know
destroys the grew by listening to this
child one thing because it is always we
disagreed with this okay
when Chad was a tender fifteen-year-old
kid 16 you were 16 and I had it written
down his 15 15s hotter
[Laughter]
gimme a skinny white guys 15 or 16 is
the same today and he worked at Safeway
yeah I would not here I went to work a
Safeway when I was 15 but the thing was
is that you said that rape between a man
and a woman was the same thing that was
the argument what no the law is okay
that's the same thing hold on it was a
chick no it's common well yeah if I
would sit up here talking about get
raped by a guy do you
you were 15 you didn't know it's got a
[ __ ] secret [ __ ] you don't [ __ ]
some of the tellers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
that actually reminds me Andy Andres and
I are going on tour
[Applause]
yeah I'm not gonna tell a story like
that my family do this it's actually
very brave I'd rather I thought I'd
clued you in during the break what the
story was I guess I forget it it was a
woman I did but I was not listening no
no yes
we were just rape doesn't sound it
sounds different when I hear it
listen that destroys the fabric I have a
visual of a safeway him in the freezer
with another dude
he's hold on to a brisket gonna [ __ ]
little girls yeah so brisket a safe
place not anymore
you do you discount meat Sega brisket
50% of now an existing suitcases of Bud
Light have handles for your convenience
oh my god frog in the throat oh my god
just meat is expired
the whole time I was waiting to hear
through you got [ __ ] by a dude I've
actually forgot the story I'm supposed
to tell forget it you I had I don't know
week ago I've already got another one in
my head so it doesn't matter what you
think I was going to bring the bar go up
and recreate can we get a break at some
point just want Margo on mic if you
could do like I'm trying to think of an
easy do wet I should that world is my
Vietnam I want shad Schenck I want shad
Schenck and Margo to do it do it
together
like my cake is an herb side evany and
ivory I'm trying to think of an easy one
that's two men islands in the stream I
just want them at Margot as you
obviously have heard on the podcast
embargo is here and every time we've had
her either to a party or a podcast or we
shot a a pilot that went nowhere
she always has a stroke right afterwards
or beforehand every time she's scheduled
she had a mini stroke during the filming
of a pilot and got up dusted herself off
and then bitter spot I didn't go to the
hospital three days later that's
[ __ ] Eriksson Margot barrio you
don't have to say anything but will you
take Erickson's chair he can do some bar
back in for a minute
just come up I just want you to talk on
mic just please just come on up walk her
up carry her up under Jesus oh don't
trust him with the purse he's a used car
salesman all right let's get back to
anyway so whatever prolongs this story
of me getting raped
so this twenty four-year-old woman
according to my notes I think I think
maybe 26 but I don't know either
wasn't there a husband involved so when
I went to work a Safeway as a bagger at
16 and when I got there as a 16 year old
I immediately singled out which cashiers
I would bang because that's how you get
salads been more determined that's all
you think about where your dad is where
can I put this I bang on hole and then
within within like three months one of
the ones that I picked out had me
in the cooler there was no brisket
involved and I was bent over quicker you
put her in a safe way I didn't know no
but we were making out in Safeway that's
where it started slow down I just want
to say it's bad enough to get raped but
to get raped in a cooler that's not
going to be your best effort as a man
and as I would be getting raped and I
would be saying at room temperature I'm
much bigger than this I didn't allow any
fondling in the cooler so she's 26 your
15 what does she look like described her
as a celebrity um I don't I don't know
how to scrimmage Oh was I had a room
name I had to do but that girl as
Monster Charlize Theron as a monster
missing as as a 16 year old this was one
of the two people that I've picked out
that I would bang so I mean she was
she's pretty hot you know to the other
yeah well the other ones were like 45
years old I was like 16
so who loved the mid-20s and they want
to go to Safeway here tomorrow and pick
out who you'd bang yeah your second
choice is gonna be over the age of 40 so
so you're in the cooler
you're stacking uh Budweiser's she comes
up behind you grabs you spins you around
you get caught off guard and she starts
kissing here you are so [ __ ] god
burden so what happened I showed you a
[ __ ] novel I was I was stacking milk
is our only differences and that third
so we see this is a new novel of running
called one shade of purple I'm just glad
you didn't call it half a shade of
purple so your sagging milk so I'm 16
years old and I end up hooking up with
this girl at Safeway we make out a lot
in the milk cooler and uh she invites me
back to her house in the evening while
her husband is at work on graveyard
shift she was grooming you ah this is
his opinion I don't I don't agree with
this I think I was uh definitely getting
great that was at the Blue Moon
bungalows hey if you're ever and uh
didn't even stay in the Waring district
go to the Blue Moon bungalows there ah
anyway that that's really all there is
to the story every guy would go well
you're well you were a victim of child
rape according to the law we're
definitely 20 something-year-old second
place finisher it molested you but I
didn't hindsight that's probably true
but thinking about it from where I was I
mean I was quite a lucky [ __ ] fellow
well look at how you are now you you
plot your own suicide by cop you have
anger issues I think it all stems back
to a girl you really wanted to [ __ ] that
was older than you [ __ ] you
but what's wrong is when you're raped
like that as a child you have really
work at it you had to do time in the
milk freezer before you even got the
invite to get raped a child I used to
tell this story in the Army and whenever
I would get accused of being a blowhard
like I or [ __ ] just talent you know
16 years old he got [ __ ] by a flavor
so then I would tell the rest of the
story to even it out
ah and now so this is Paul Harvey oh the
first arrest doesn't occur every time
the first time her husband was was out
of town and she invited me over I of
course went over immediately parked in a
secluded spot when in the [ __ ]
downstairs door went inside I am Susan
globe Arizona that she lived in a
secluded spot wait so can I tell you
right now I'm imagining the Tempe improv
condo you know that condo I saw Mike
it's in the book keep going I I have no
idea what the [ __ ] reference you just
made but I'm going to keep going
globe Arizona is like Benson that we
drove to it's yeah it's a trailer park
there's a three-legged dog with this net
source from sriracha you're way off
you're way off if you knew anything
about globe Arizona the fact that I said
her husband was on graveyard shift would
let you know that he worked at the mines
which is top level [ __ ] globe Arizona
this is you somehow Miner's Daughter is
there oh my bad oh that's a difference I
loved it so you go to cover this part -
I'm ready you're at her house no matter
house we go in the basement door go in
the back grab some fudgesicles cuz
you're 60 no idea what doing crack into
those bomb pops
almost any got hard [ __ ] you guys I'm
about to demean myself incredibly I
don't need your help
well you're going to make one of it so
you're listening to Will Smith and
Jackie Joe
so on your walkman
I go to put it in and yeah with them
what do you do I assume the parking lot
I was no house icicle
I'm walking around that part I didn't
lose the foot sickled waiting somebody
victory
oh no we're still going it okay this is
nice so you bring teachers a basement so
the security cameras can't catch you
well this was probably early 90s no
security cameras no but uh back where
you could say the uncommon whatever here
this is my favorite thing I've ever
heard uh come on a fudgesicle with a
Walkman on oh I'm gonna pocket 26 year
old [ __ ] good the next part is not going
to help that story anymore so so like a
16 year old who got invited to the
basement of a married 26 year old I
finish immediately yes but I don't have
the knowledge to know that she knows
what just happened
like I don't I don't think she realizes
I just laid a load everywhere so I
immediately tried to claim the high road
and I was like I don't think I can do
this cuz you're married you're married
you're very what hey you're gonna finish
the spectacles in here you know what my
positive is melting you should have
dripped it on her back ya know they the
worst part of that is she invited me
back so many times after that the first
time I [ __ ] that up so bad how did you
invite me back the first time I had sex
with my wife okay
okay dad has the same story okay you
fairy
you've heard about Burke's wife yeah
that's the joke I came really quick
and I I told her I thought this is
genius I went I think someone's breaking
into my house and I got off it laughs
put on a new comedy came back my god
nothing yes the next day wait wait were
you 16 years old because that's the only
defense I have in my head I loved it we
do the exam fees I don't need to feel
like a [ __ ] oh [ __ ] me let's just talk
for a little while huh do the first time
I ever had sex with the gym no one's
ever made me feel that good ever do that
one it comes too quick you like my god
you're the first woman you make their
ego you put it on them like no one has
ever made me [ __ ] that [ __ ] hey stop it
and I'm still a man I didn't remember
your name or ask for your phone number
honey this was true I don't orgasm the
other night it was really quick and my
wife got it right when it happened she
thought happening in my eyes and she
went oh look at him who else is in the
room talking to someone oh look at him I
feel like I don't even know if I do
stand-up I did I just tell secrets
I am [ __ ] hammered all right little
bit what will we call Mike always I'll
point you that please don't you
i I gotta get to Erickson story because
I know I'm gonna look not going to be
better than what we just heard well oh I
wish I want there's no rapist just
smoked weed earlier everybody Hanigan
because you [ __ ] you want to save this
one yeah yeah just for us this is a that
you did let's do it quickly
because Bert might know how this [ __ ]
works
Hennigan Stu [ __ ] and I don't want to
switch people out anymore until the end
I I would love to get shawcroft up maybe
if she's still Andy with no teeth if you
read my book digging up mother where we
lived where Hennigan lives now and
Ericsson lives same apartment complex if
you wanted to get rid of [ __ ] you could
just put it on the sidewalk and we
called it leaving it out for the
Russians because it's a Russian
immigrant slash gay neighborhood never
come up no cross mingling gaya Russian
but they would scavenge anything and
Hennigan said all right so so we got a
new couch we put our old couch on the
street for the Russians to have and we
all in the apartment building bet
whether the calyx would last 24 hours or
not and within six hours all the
cushions were gone
and we find out that would happen is the
apartment manager had to throw the
cushions away because the homeless guy
took a [ __ ] on the couch so the cushions
are gone and we're like well who's going
to take the couch now it's never no
one's going to take it and then a couple
hours later I hear I hear this
motorcycle pull up like a chopper style
like everything you're [ __ ] here in
today right like this
rub rub rub rub and it pulls up and it
stops and I thought they went into the
building next door because it stopped it
didn't just go by and then I'm like
maybe a minute later it starts back up
we heard I'm like what the [ __ ] going
on I look out the window and this dude
is on a chopper like with long Forks
tiny wheel full biker dude like with the
Lemmy Kilmister [ __ ] mustache biker
vest and everything even even the old
German [ __ ] helmet with the [ __ ]
point
spike on it like one of the [ __ ]
black widows from every which way but
loose what was great ready and you just
hear it's like a pump pump pump any
[ __ ] pulls out and I'm like what the
[ __ ] and I look and he's got a rope tied
to the back of his motorcycle lassoed
around the couch and he just pulls it
down the street not in a cart not on
anything just and there goes my [ __ ]
cows towards Santa Monica Boulevard cos
and and and the best part is right on
our street corner there's a four-way
stop sign so the very first thing that
happens is he has to stop because
there's another car at the you can't
just blow through it there's another car
so he stops and of course the couch
doesn't stop it I'm just lighting up it
doesn't hit him
it stops before it hits him but then the
car goes by so he hits the gas and then
the slack in the rope tightness and it's
a [ __ ] cow shanks and all the couch
legs fall off but he just pulls it right
down the [ __ ] Street there it goes by
pouch
about an hour later Carrie Mitchell went
down to the 7-eleven and she's like I
found her couch it's at the 7-eleven the
first Locker away the first left or it
couldn't I can handle it was over with
well I know exactly where you live right
now we we had a got a new mattress from
Casper Casper mattresses oh we get to
Casper mattress I am over swept on it
Brian's gonna sleep on it tonight -
they're really good and so we got rid of
our old mattress that wasn't really a
sponsor and we are a sponsor but we're
not getting paid for this so I said I
said I problem the new mattress we had
the old mattress and apparently if
you're white you you have to recycle it
and so our our yard guy are y'all guys
Mexican and he goes I'll just put it in
the [ __ ] alley and I go really and he
goes hey I'm putting the AL to be gone
in 25 minutes and I said and then he's
read it back in his truck up in the
alley yeah you hear a chopper yeah I'm
[ __ ] hammered hi
I didn't know if you're going somewhere
the rules are story's over that's the
reason the rules were I've done is hard
I'm not this is the [ __ ] [ __ ] have
lots of the [ __ ] years since the last
time you're in the fun out the glass I
wasn't busy
I'm trying to save myself for the after
party I know we have an after party oh
yeah we have to add to party so yeah
we're getting close
one thing that we have to do I was going
to do that but this is just soft but for
road people we have to close on the
three biographies we have to close on
that I'm going to tell you mine okay
Shaw Croft inspired yeah I want to just
give her the mic and just stay over her
cold early stay like a so residence in
infinite you know when when Margaret
show is in rehab they let her do shows
but they'd have a sober sitter
stand right as soon as she yeah make
sure she doesn't go haywire the Ojai
winter ahead bird make out with
everybody like won the Stanley Cup in
Toronto where three years in a row
why do you act like I'm bad I'm dreaming
ready really filled heart Amman okay
this is this was gonna be a beyond thing
oh you've gotta beat that Bert Kreischer
than a pizza delivered in Bisbee how's
Vanessa Oh Labor Day yes just tell how
we fell in love neighbor Dave I couldn't
get a pizzas delivered when me and Tom
roads were on mushrooms with Joby and
that's how I met my neighborhood I went
out hi out of my tent with charcoal eyes
and five o'clock on I'll give you a
hundred dollars if you go get us a pizza
it's a long story but that's how you
meet your neighbors
we don't deliver unless you're burnt
Kreischer well sweetie look at her
smiling next show
it's good all right this is this is kind
of you inspired oh isn't as Road comics
do you tip or not tip actually Haley
I've ever had not jelly
Hennigan it would be in your seat right
now but no no no no his answer would
always be no who doesn't know all right
but stay close
put him in put them in I want to do this
with you I'm gonna make this quick Elmen
and just call or not oh and no don't
yep why do you tip cuz you I know you
tipped housekeeping Bert yeah 20 bucks
yes really
yeah I keep housekeeping on always time
for long time oh my god and you leave
the room like a [ __ ] seventeen to
babies let luffa with plastic that's
true oh hang on I bingo
so wait let me let me introduce Lynne
properly years ago ah little ready oh
yeah I'm gonna do I supposed to do this
but I forgot we were no no would you no
no it's not okay
anal story everything isn't an anal oh
my God if I have not had anal sex with
you just tell me right now I'm all ears
that's the point we don't know exactly
we did a show in downtown LA as it was
just becoming gentrified and Garrett
Morris had a club down there and though
we all get there was cocaine involved
there every good story several fingers
have look shocked Rob the book I'm
writing it's just like Road stories with
a thin through line my favorite thing is
it when I called you and you told me
about the letter in like Dayton about we
hang on reading let me know don't see
don't get me off topic
that's why you were not gonna be here
till the end but just no shark roaring
any story I was mourning and vulnerable
let me get right into the story then you
can rebut I get the [ __ ] county
prosecutor here he can do this like a
regular trial yes I except my rape
conviction oh I'm just saying a lot of
the stories in my book are
cocaine-related where it gives a false
illusion that I'm a coke coke head but
no those are the ones you remember when
you guys drunk you forget what if you do
coke you wish you forgot the other hand
I don't cook that much I just remember
so one night there was a you and I and
bingo and we're doing this Garrett
Morris
we're all loose it was a six days er
about here thanks mom
sax was sadder than any morning
last week the next morning we all wake
up go back to our respective on any of
us hotel rooms we don't know that point
being we were so [ __ ] up that we all
assumed everyone else involved in the
story had blacked it out yeah we were
the only people that remembered and we
shut our mouths no one talked about it
though because we know I know you don't
remember she knows we don't remember
nobody remembers we all had a personal
moment it was mine was dark and rate art
wasn't always really great a year later
we're at the Coach and Horses Ellenton
[ __ ] up in LA that [ __ ] up that it's
the last time I remember vomiting I was
so drunk I don't I'm not a puker yeah in
high school but I remember like Oh draw
accent
see this is why she can't oh my god
she will not like our show here I can't
feel like the tension I could get in
trouble at any time yes or no isn't this
segment I want to take all right boys
all right we were that drunk a year
later and you turn to us as we're trying
to get over-served more at the coaching
horses hello hey you remember that time
of year ago when we all [ __ ] like I
don't know you remember go oh you
remember - oh no witness died never
happened yeah and I still can't black it
out anyway Lynch our cross but I don't
know what happened
bingo did it happen that was bingo
Doug Stanhope and I and normally it
would be like you commenting I'd
remember I [ __ ] a hero and Doug
Stanhope last night
but I don't know but I did wake up and I
looked at bingo we were in the same bed
in Bingle look down shouldn't have
underwear on she went and ran out the
butt so I don't know and I felt that was
before her vaginoplasty when anyone
looking at her vagina would run out of
the room but no she's beautiful but I
can't believe it happen and I'm
embarrassed and I just want to apologize
it's like oh you can't apologize enough
and one last thing that was the night
that it like remember it didn't end with
remember we had a threesome I went out
and washed my face in oh that was the
year later yeah you smell yeah yeah we
could go on with that plan immorally
doing it how does anything learn look
how I could bring this back around
vision tip housekeeping that night and
get back to the original thing do you
Brian Hannigan do you tip when you go to
sushi yes blue
you know how the sushi guy has a
separate jar than the waitress do you
tip that jar I'd never give that jar
Burt do you tip that jar here's the
thing and when I came here is obviously
I'm from Scotland in the UK and they're
from I'm slightly tight fisted but does
Doug imbued me with this idea of tipping
from [ __ ] everything and I've gone
like like born-again Christian tipping I
sit [ __ ] everyone yep for the record
you were born right yeah after Stanhope
then that's pretty - I've seen this guy
- [ __ ] yeah twice to build oh yeah
it's not I believe it's over today I
used to do it that's on the list don't
get ahead of me I do this thing called
up I used to sing called what would the
maid think where I'd leave the room in a
ridiculous way the first time I did it I
didn't tip and then someone I left what
I did is I took my shirt from the day of
shooting and I put it over a pillow and
I put it in the frigerator so it looked
like a human torso in the refrigerator
it was in San Antonio Texas I didn't tip
and boy before that it was called cheap
dick yeah and so uh and then and then my
camera guy was like hey man if you do
that you should tip so I know until one
hundred bucks on housekeeping a hundred
why need change that was in my pocket
because I don't even get my wrong they
don't trust them
you've on there for five days I don't
live in my [ __ ] room ever get my [ __ ]
wait a little bit it even even when you
do the Axe body spray trick you know
we've learned that now now that we smoke
in rooms and then we allege it allegedly
yeah but I think of all people you and
bingo should tip twice what you're
paying the [ __ ] room because I've
seen how you've left room oh I'm fired
I'm not sure I'm right it's true [ __ ]
ghetto of India yeah it's the worst but
that's why I don't let them into clean
yeah no I understand I honest all right
sushi we got past that bathroom
attendants where they're forced upon you
yes yes yes nope oh yes
I won't even wash my hands all right
yeah Chad let's start with Chad you and
we dealt with that word I know life I've
never been in a bathroom whether it's in
attendance oh yeah no I don't have this
problem
but if I did I would be broke so I would
not him I don't I'll even avoid we have
their psyche we're toilet and bathroom
are still used as in demeaning terms
you're talking about someone who's
willing to stand 2-1 in such places and
hands you something that makes you feel
pleasant after you've done your business
I feel the very least you could afford
them is the dignity of a [ __ ] couple
of [ __ ] bugs doctor and that's why
you are
from the USA hey I just want to know
what happened to the real Brian Hanigan
because that is some [ __ ] right
there are you serious i why are you
lying
I went on the beat on an abuse based
holiday to Victor Australia
well anyway okay here's the important
thing here's the important one I know
you don't know the answer to this but it
infuriates me the situation where you
want to tip and you're forbidden Oh to
me an example I'll tell you it target
flight attack place upended flight
attendants let let the brilliance of her
one word report soak in and then wait
attendant I used to I used to implore
you the killer termites to do this is
when because as you've seen in the news
recently when a flight attendant is a
[ __ ] to you if you just say something
snarky she'll find a reason to have you
thrown off the bed yeah you've been
dragged to you so I always used to say
what you do because you can't as you say
tips flight attendants when you get your
drink or whatever your pretzels tipper
recorder oh no no it's easier cut if
she's a [ __ ] don't get thrown off the
plane wait till she brings to peanuts
and go here's free him and tag it with a
will and a fake oshiruko I can't accept
tips go but you're worth it and you how
are they gonna have you thrown off the
plane he tried to give me money that
wasn't enough
he insulted my finger when our plane
would be the scariest thing ever
more like a [ __ ] sinkhole oh no my
role is much worse than anything um
before the planes start getting in your
living room
and the floor drops out from underneath
you as opposed to sir need to take your
plane go away
unless you unless you're jerking off to
take your big head followed in sinkholes
there [ __ ] sinkholes are very clever let
me get the limbs are proper portion of
this done because she will yell over
everybody is that me what is that
is it very chakra Hannah
tipping Queen Starbucks slash counter
service hi Martha you pick up a piece of
that pizza where you get it to go or if
you're getting something like those they
have a tip jar yes I'm on always 10%
always don't ever say go to the bank on
Wednesdays and I take $100 and I turn it
into one so I could tip the world
check me out a Rite Aid Josh I heard
it's aperture opens a weird case we can
get [ __ ] I pick [ __ ] anything and
everything cuz it's about connecting the
human oh so that's how you connect you
just give a bunny so yeah no I love it
you and Charlie Sheen oh no I'm trying
to 30 no because sometimes you make a
friend over a dollar but a terrible
first purchase we're doing [ __ ] that did
the brawl you don't even care about but
are listening comic audience room
service when you know they already into
Zipporah Tunney how do you work a bird
go let bird go first
let me explain to that when you get room
service on the road when you have
disposable income because you don't have
children and you didn't make those bad
choices sometimes you get room service
and but what you don't know four years
in when you get room service
they already include a gratuity there's
not twenty four percent already in but
what you don't is not that well I have a
query liar anyway but they also leave a
space for you to tip so you don't know
they already include little city tip yep
I've made that every time every time I
say to him uh so we'll do a little
role-playing right now you guys be the
waiter yeah be me ago as typically and
I'll go yeah it is no all cool
and you can't I just put a line through
it and I write the total I do that again
double get me [ __ ] yeah but
shock off go ahead succinctly um is a
tip already included yes I'll [ __ ] tip
you again well would it know what I
found out and there's add and all of
your family surf industry style when
tonight if you're paying with credit
card what I found out with room service
is they take a chunk of the tips from
the house takes a chunk of the [ __ ]
already included dip I in the hotel know
when you give them cash always tip off
always
here's a bad day baby
Wow get to brush your teeth and tip and
care what I do in restaurants often I'll
tip you tell them 5% on the official
bill so that I look like a cheapskate
but it still looks like a tip and then I
give the other 15% in cash to the person
directly
yeah and that way they get either the
biggest out that's that was partial
political correctness and partial he's
not from this country when he says
cheapskate it's not a racial slur about
tipping he can't use every car damaged
my god that's but also I heard more
needed to see it it was a black people
don't tip joke Jesus [ __ ] I want to go
back to I want to go back to the flight
apparently the one time one time I saw
Hennigan tip humongous was when you had
his credit card and we ate breakfast
Haley did that when he had my credit
card he was tweeting me pictures of my
credit card when he was buying an
airport lounge where every drink is $14
cloud terminal in LAX with your hair I
love you I met a lot of people that day
hey let me wanna cry with you what can I
do want it as a very venomous residue
you can't hit a petting zoo and is it
money or penis only the cows would can
we go buy I want to find a declared
enclosed whale Eilat before we get off
the shipping thing let's don't get off
the tipping story yet because you know I
don't know the whole thing of it but
Burt does a like a week that raffle that
I don't know he would better explain
that I can yeah I was I was in I was in
um in New Jersey at a comedy club what's
in that club scary just factory and I
had $100 extra then I'm just going to
staff then I was like ah [ __ ] it member
will raffle it off and then I thought if
we got everyone in the crowd to give a
dollar we can make it $300 oh and it
turned out being like $700 and yeah and
I've been doing it a lot I've been doing
it a big show it's my wife likes it
that's the probably the reason we
should've brought this up because you're
not doing it our drugs were you doing
want to do it
just everyone pass her much waitresses
here Casey Morgan this after-party Haley
old woman Haley made all of this happen
Gretchen and Shaunie
recreated the Panos there's too many
people that say hey I'm gonna clear the
stage hold on let me start you Shaunie
bill says Greg Lee and painted it they
did a fantastic job let's hear for them
at the after-party we're doing a 50-50
raffle first prize is 50% of what we
collect the other 50% goes to studio
Mariposa which is in NACO for Gretchen
we also have second second place is
going to get we've got the entire Mitch
Hedberg vinyl collection that second
place and third third place will be Ron
White number one tequila we got we got
to follow that that's all over as after
parties we won't always come over in a
hand up for that but yeah this is this
is a lot of people with the wrap this up
because the wiper box that should be
number one
no no let's wait I made it dumb [ __ ]
that we're almost at two hours you know
rice is going to last another [ __ ]
tetris I'll talk about blue apron if you
want to get done get a look at him Haley
yeah we can talk about blue apron Haley
needs your seat we're gonna gonna close
this up because I knew it I knew it
Haley's gonna lay it off
you can you're gonna hang out I'm gonna
let person despite what [ __ ] hang out
with Renard
I just need Kaylie here because this is
the third podcast I've done with Bert
Kreischer and we always do of what comic
would you pick kind of thing yeah the
first time it was I don't know favorite
comics then what would your all-star
tour be and we pick the comedians like
kickball and this time we're going to do
what comedians biography would you want
to read meaning not autobiography like
David hell I use as an example the best
comic of my generation hands down yeah
but I know his daily life is just so
some these missile didn't yeah I'm gonna
quit everything sucks every yeah I don't
want to read a biography I wanna like if
you could know the deep dark secrets of
any comedian and we haven't put haha
[ __ ] he's got two kids we think he has
an interesting day now someone yelled
Bert Kreischer eyes how are you [ __ ]
about you the UH
when you said this uh it was my favorite
thing I'm obsessed with this I have a
woman to do a podcast one time where I
just told I had comics on and they told
their best stories about other comics so
I believe like that is the true like the
best thing hanging out with you is great
but hearing stories about you is better
it was that example and so I wanted to
do a podcast where we just have people
tell like San home stories and then do
an hour podcasts of every comment
telling their set up stories mine is
going to be a sleeper it's someone that
I'm really infatuated with and I hope
you know because it's how you said this
to me I thought I loved it let me
because I only have
one in my head and I pitch this you have
to the rule only rule living or dead we
haven't discussed dead my only rule is
that it's actually seeing their real
life a hundred percent no a home on it
yes someone else is an account the life
that flashed before their eyes if they
were dying
go ahead you get to pick first J
Medicine had a battle over there early
do you this is we're trying to take
googling he didn't pay it out just for
comics listening later when this goes
out you won't know J Medicine Hat he was
a originally a comic named something
different then turned himself into a
admitted as that was paying bills and a
I don't think he's even a Native
American to be honest with you no he's
not yeah and don't know about by the way
this is why I reckon kenny bang bang
it's like a guy yeah I need I need a new
rack this is why I want his biography
like my favorite biography is a to the
biography on the Sex Pistols on their
tour through the south it was horrible
like their tour was horrible but like
this dude was fascinating he used to
tour every funnybone every four months
he did every funny bone and he made
legit money and he sold out everywhere
and and you get on stage sometimes go
[ __ ] it I don't feel it and he'd walk
off lots of cocaine lots of whiskey and
died of a stroke and a target dude
that's the guy I've read that look yeah
absolutely I'm fascinated by that guy he
was because as a comic as a road comic
you hear him there's another guy he's
not in my list but uh John the ragin
Cajun [ __ ] raising Cajun Oh John nobody
here knows common oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
right comedy all right done I got I got
mine are going to be goat you got it
minor deep so like if you're a podcast
fan you'll hear mine and then you'll
google them and go shut the [ __ ] up but
I'm ready to hear yes one of one of the
things that you said to me when I said
what we have to do that we have to
continue the tradition of what comic
versus what comic I realized when you
say J Medicine Hat you go you know the
ones I have you're not gonna like and
then when you said it I go oh I like it
they won't like it yeah I never put the
live audience in the they won't get J
Medicine hang no but they shouldn't make
sure you realize there's no comedians
anymore that you want to hear their
stories oh no more kinnison's there's no
more I tell about I tell you my whole
story on Instagram you know what the
[ __ ] I'm doing like okay I don't have
any secrets like oh yeah I'm on
blood-pressure medicine i I'm addicted
to xanax like yeah those are all the
things about me but there are guys out
there I'm gonna do number two oh no I
get to pick all Stoke okay you don't
pick my kids ball I'm gonna go I'm going
last - I just thought of it when you
goddamnit I uh
[ __ ] this mother thank you she would do
Q&A I know no no no flow not now not so
into the husband game that's all I had
to get off the line ah me oh no you
don't get to go [ __ ] alright I'm going
with my number one because she's here
but it's true and that's the only bank
of knowledge my number one is Hedberg
Mitch Hedberg because
100% shut it this stop died that's why I
didn't want it I wouldn't say that to
last but I just thought of someone else
that was a [ __ ] nail I'll think of it
when you but Mitch Hedberg his wife Lynn
chakra is the only one that knows the
[ __ ] stories and she's writing the
book and that's Hedberg was [ __ ] so
unique and amazing but she's the only
one that knows the details of the last
10 years
so go ahead uh this dude told a story
one times you just say who about Mitch
Hedberg because we'll go whoa well
roundtable a litany of us dearly hope
you win second prize at the 50-50 raffle
because you will [ __ ] love it and you
have to have a record player turned a
negative and a positive is amazing go
ahead feel like I feel like I should
save my closer for my closer and to tell
you am I not
as we're doing 3 right yeah ok I'm gonna
say my closer yeah yet number 2 number 2
Eric Myers Eric Myers is a comedian who
has a distinct drinking problem beyond
what you'll ever wrap your head around
he is a guy who I heard about fer I
worked with him louis c.k and he was
like I'm not drinking I'm just taking
xanax and I thought oh wow this sounds
horrible then he liquidated his [ __ ]
his credit card and bought all audio and
video equipment in West Palm right I was
like god this guy's on tilt so I go to
the Richmond funnybone and they go yeah
yeah yeah we had to fire him he got
drunk in between shows and piss on the
couch
this guy has the most [ __ ] amazing
stories about one time he got arrested
at the Cincinnati funnybone walking from
the seafood restaurant the globus excuse
me so drunk and he went got arrested and
indicted for the Bisby people that's
like getting arrested at the VFW hall
going to the Second Amendment gun shop
it's a strip mall it's [ __ ] got
arrested tried to get on a plane Sunday
they wouldn't let along she was too
drunk passed out in the shower and his
dad had to come and put him in rehab
this guy's got [ __ ] stories if I want
to read a book
it is ladies and gentlemen Eric by
alright alright well done but you're
hearing his stories here I go to hear
the truth yeah that they had nothing to
do with writing I'm going Ralphie may as
my number two
[Applause]
I've been steering him going I got
nothing i got nothing and then I got
Ralphie May like oh we're just going
biography Ralphie bein so full of [ __ ]
he tells me stories about me that I was
there for
bloviate all these lies into a little do
we went had sushi one time he's a
beautiful guy but he he just like so
much I just want to know what like if
there was a hidden camera on someone's
life a hidden camera is a perfect part
and I when we were there at his house we
you said he didn't even need to lie
about that part now I know he's
old-fashioned roll around the refund he
didn't have to say thirty people got the
refund he told his story when we were
young kids and I had a mullet and we
played the last stop before beat Pirelli
the [ __ ] good days of Mark Babbitt we
went to a water park with Ralphie May if
you don't know him he's
a rotund person of over 7,000 pounds
[Laughter]
look I get it he handles record he has
neighbor Dave on his vision board one
day baby I could be that petite and
there's this giant waterslide and used
to the tube thing and you have to climb
six storeys of stairs to get and Ralphie
made her get to the top they won't let
him on the ride cuz he's obviously too
fat but they should had to sign down at
the first level so they made him do the
walk of shame back down oh and we were
wrong climbing by the way more accidents
happen on the descent than the ascent
because I mean if you ever got insurance
people might in my family so okay so I
use this we're not rich we're broke
comics like whatever 20 bucks to get in
was a lot of money so I go don't worry
Ralphie I'm going to use this as an
excuse to get our money back and I threw
a fit you humiliated my obese friend and
I did that and we got our money back and
there were three of us but when we were
just at his house last year he tells his
story where feriss I told the manager
there's 25 people and we got $30 and
please the dougie Stano brought us out
for lobster because they paid us how
does that happen
there were three of us a chargeback on
my visa
back then it was probably the VC you get
when you have to put money down though
but still I don't know I didn't have a
suit why do you have to lie to me about
my story like I do are you saying what
my therapist says and by the way hold on
he was trouble as a gentleman he didn't
say anything he just kicked me under the
table and we talked about it later and
then now we talk about him no I actually
told Ralph Ian I go no that never
happened he said that to his face but he
kept arguing now if I remembered a
lobster and everyone like you're wrong
I'm not gonna argue anyway go you're
number one number one I'm an
autobiography I will let you chime in if
you think of a comic that you really
want to know what their life was like
that you would never know otherwise so
you want so obviously I have a storied
past with alcohol so sometimes comics
will reach out to you when they're going
to hard times that they're not going to
our time sky told me a story one time my
favorite story ever and this is why he's
my number one he had a gig at Harvard he
was in New York and he was doing crack
and he was doing a lot of it and they
couldn't find him for like two days and
then they found him and his manager said
listen the gig pays like 25 grand the
cars downstairs getting a [ __ ] car
man
so he gets in the car do you know I'm
talking about Oh any idea if he gets in
the car he's got a bunch of crack enough
to get him to Boston how much had a
problem and a bottle of vodka bottle of
vodka he starts realizing I'm a dad I'm
a [ __ ] I've been there a lot he starts
crying obsessively in this limo gets all
the way to Boston and he's been sobbing
smoking crack and drinking vodka the
whole time when he pulls into Boston he
realizes that the partition for the
limousine has been down the entire time
and that is why my number one is greg
Giraldo girl that honesty that honesty
that you share with another comic that
I'll share with Doug I'll share with
other with these guys I don't really
share it on stage
totally but we all share it at moments
man greg Giraldo one time I got offered
a speed on off a switchblade at a bar
called sure shots in Dayton and I
realized that's where he wrote this joke
I think I fisted a girl there I have a
hoodie of a hoodie from sure shots in
Dayton and I know that that's where that
happened for Greg and I wear it all the
time they get excited I miss I miss him
genuinely he was the sweetest dude in
the world but man Thank You Aldo for the
Bisbee crew that they don't [ __ ] know
comedy that's why I can live here
peacefully they don't give a [ __ ]
greg Giraldo was a brilliant comedian
that had quit law to do stand-up comedy
and did it well and then would get
[ __ ] up on drugs and alcohol but then
go right back into a lawyers state of
mind go through rehab and then be nor he
wasn't like me I'm a [ __ ] all the time
music I images was Jason turns into me I
turn into Jason guy turns into me it was
a revolving door and then he is in my
new book which you can order pre-order
on Amazon later a there is a greg
Giraldo book coming out so really yeah
they contacted me to ask me about what's
involved with the audio book reading and
yeah but so yeah I did a little Craig
throttle book there is a greg Giraldo
book coming out look on twitter greg
Giraldo book all right yeah Hanna give
me you said you were gonna you were at
number three you had one I vomited by
art I got review current existing
living comedians who I think their their
biography not the way they'd write it
but Allah Oh an obvious one whose are
intellectually thrilling comedian Maria
Bamford
I think her biography being outstanding
and somebody who's completely overlooked
in the so-called dark areas of comedy
Skype use where you leave you out on
orders on iris or Steve Hughes the
Australian guy Nick he's out our dough
Steve Muse I love you if he knows don't
you use okay knows Carl Taylor because
poor heavy-metal drummer has done all
sorts of [ __ ] when he goes off the radar
he doesn't go over like a soft hallway
he's going off because it has to go off
I'm gonna go take a piss he goes on now
you're making but what's the way we've
applied the rules of just not thereby
autobiography but what the [ __ ] you know
where I'm going and I'm not gonna save
the day I just want to applaud dick of
his look on hey look can we take your
papers your third he's gonna take a piss
are you gonna be everyone wait for your
third no no I was I was I was gonna I'm
trying to not say the Steve Hughes name
that you reminded me of oh I'd love to
see what you're [ __ ] doing behind the
curtain of odd hey can i yes Australian
guys there's no time
so in in South Africa Mia Steve Hughes
and Alliston barrier I should say his
name my bleeping you might do hope they
don't get a holding a little bit get a
little nope nope no door not gonna get a
hold a little bit of cocaine and we end
up just partying in Steve's room and
Steve says I'm a [ __ ] amazing drummer
so I put on rush I go can you air drum
to this and he goes you know Steve
auditors that night
alright let's go and [ __ ] air drum to
Russ and me about the barriers of
thought our [ __ ] ass
Oh
[Music]
like Tom Sawyer or YYZ counselor I'm
sorry I'm talking Tom Sawyer we get over
there any was doing the [ __ ] he would
do this here we go like this
hold it there yellow despair he he can
watch the snare he would grab it like it
was all air-drumming and Alison are
losing our [ __ ] minds
this looks unreal that is when I found
out we had coke they go we got sorted
out night I what's happening they go we
got cocaine sounds like the cops are
coming it was the man's how that was a
great time those the UK comics and none
of them were UK comics they were all
Australian yeah yeah Diamond Jim
Jeffries he moved to Manchester but they
had such a tolerance for drugs Glenn
wool yeah a Canadian now London that he
was it was the three I remember seeing
him walking past me going oh I've been
awake for three days and I have to do
ecstasy to do a children's party is that
gonna look like days and I was already
going in the book Holly Libra has to be
the name your vote that's in the book no
that's in the last book oh I think I'm
telling him [ __ ] I already know Ella
you're not gonna relased your third I
did I had [ __ ] you did help our
unibrow in May what would Steve Hughes
ermine job I or justice are another
Australian community I have a third guy
Jeff yeah I would like I would love to
have a Jim Jeffries biography we have
you have you have yet listen I love Jim
no one but I will today I want to have a
I would like I would love a third party
writing of his life that what were the
yeah yeah yeah yeah but like like
because I blue things of the obsesses I
obsess about is like the things I said
one time on stage and people got
offended and the thing that made Jim
Jefferies was that he got beat up on the
store and yeah and
we'll be doing Hema Hema bill I love
Dober but when he did that [ __ ]
Philly they are the philly thing dude
ah that's different that is same same a
little knowest no it's because you're
hustling ro because bill burr went out
there and confronted a seething mass and
shoved their indignity in hatred back in
their face and made it funny
spontaneously in the moment yeah you do
it without a result they threw batteries
at Santa Claus for Jeffrey Miller Jim
Jefferies has Jim Jefferies he that that
store thing
Brett Vincent put it online and it was
amazing but also the thing that I love
about Jim's career is that like he's got
that one bit that every two months goes
viral if there's a school shooting he's
got to show a bit about our guns and so
every time there's a school shooting it
goes viral and I racked my brain about
like what is the one thing that's good
like shark attacks like I rack my brain
going hell I am
I am several bits about not just school
shootings but shootings in general and
mass murder but they're all pro so they
never go viral
oh I shall choke kills a bunch of people
listen to stand of it about why they
killed more people when our killing
people and this doesn't really take off
as potato live liberal left medias
keeping me down I just want people day I
want y'all to care but I also want dead
people with us that's why mitad best
line out of stand-up from 2017 is I'm
working this corner yeah we open this
one oh okay oh I did that bit here on
stage down as the basis China alright
we're gonna yeah we're wrapping up right
let's do it you want to do the
commercial
we're done blue aver everybody we're at
two hours people aboard blue apron Tom
cannot go sorry we couldn't have you on
this one
there are the others don't forget that
over in the gulch I guess this brewery
Road right across from Elmo's is the
after party or we lose everything
Lavigne was here we never got her on we
got a we got a mic set up over there
we've got a stage in about an hour you
can head over there
we got merch for sale out there and he's
got a list he keeps buzzing it's too
late it's too like we're out of time
because with union [ __ ] so I was
supposed to do I was supposed to make
the announcement about Johnny Depp is
buying the loma linda but let's say that
let's say that
ladies and gentlemen thank you so much
for coming out - shake right erikson
right Hennigan Lynn stop Rock birthday
[Applause]
just add up our bartenders crazy and
bingo
Griffin Joshua and everyone here at the
Royale thank you very much for coming
out
hangout order constraints roof will be
out a minute will be a submerged booth
just relax
we're all gonna have some fun thank you
thank you so much I hate the truth
always segue in the hip-high more
YouTube it didn't it didn't it didn't it
didn't it didn't it depicted the
derivative the despondent I'm desirable
to be identified
Dominican is delivered into fog - time
to drink your drink
then eat your peas it's not the time to
be lap your lap does your piece it
spawned a time smile your smile
[ __ ] desire to medical Tsugumi dance the
dance
party time Hong Kong the sake of shock
yeah Oh baby drop your crackdown sake of
time it's pop the time to grab your drop
down [ __ ] you punk
it's thought it died in the morning drop
your [ __ ] socks off big time
all good drop your ground
did I
[Applause]
Brogdon I'm intimidated
design the pasta time pasta time watch
this time but this time monster time
rocket time pasta time on this time hey
[Music]
deposit time